okay
oh we did this one right
and i'm going to take her right into the
technique
i'm not taking her down anymore but i'm
using this whole thing
to do the same level of
a control thing right into it
i'm not going to tilt her
i'm turning her whole body
you don't have to do anything i'll do it
turn her whole body
you know she's not going down anymore
right
they turned her whole body i'm gonna
doesn't matter if you go fast or slow
slow as you can harder like move the
whole body around
okay
let's try it
um
what
so we remember when we were doing the
drill right that i'm
in your center you see i'm in her center
even as i start to turn i'm not just
yielding you see
uh and i'm using the outward spiral dc
so it's always in her center always in
the center oh i'm floating around the
edge here i'm gonna go from two hands
right the two hands are gonna move you
you see
okay
so
in the center in the center in the
center boom the two hands move till i
transition to these two hand position
you see uh so this is what's controlling
her okay i don't want to break her
center i'm gonna move her center that's
what i'm doing okay we'll get back where
we were
you know okay and now what i'm going to
do is instead of the shape where i took
her down i'm going to take her into the
back outward kazushi which is
okay
so i'm gonna move her body in a way
that i get that shape there it is
you guys see that
what i don't want to do
is bend her over
and pull her back
and then
do that technique
no matter how i do that i don't want to
do that i don't want to enter in the
back right and then
get her casey like i don't want to do
that and that's
clash
if you pay attention i'm basically doing
her whole center so she's going to go
forward
and then into the figure eight and into
the back outward kazushi but i have to
move her whole center there it is right
there
okay
again you can kind of you do all kinds
of weird things with this it looks like
how much going on
but she can feel
that her whole body full the whole body
is moving okay
the whole body
you get it from where i'm touching okay
all right
oh missed you there
oh you did that don't do anything for me
please
there you go oh yeah no wonder you were
doing it
don't step don't step
don't step got it don't do anything
watch
there it is
[Music]
don't step
oh you did look do you see i did it
you don't step i make you step
made
[Music]